quand jean-pierre foucault d'entendre
micro elles veulent sauver le monde
aider les animaux et est médecin et puis
finalement deviennent animatrice de télé
où elle épouse un footballeur mais ce
sont des mauvaises langues il n'en fait
pas partie lépine est ce que cette
petite musique merci bonsoir à tous est
ce que est ce que vous êtes d'accord ce
que vous venez de voir c'est évidemment
c'est un petit rigolo le sujet mais que
grosso modo ba'alawy miss france après
c'est soit femmes de footballeurs soient
de la télé soit l'espace c'est pas faux
on voit qu'il ya beaucoup de filles qui
vont avec des sportifs parce que les
sportifs doivent être très sympa et très
très beau et et que dans les soirées
sans doute qu'elle les rencontres mais
en tout cas celles qui veulent faire de
la télé effectivement miss france c'est
un super tremplin est par exemple moi
maintenant j'ai la chance depuis six ans
bientôt sept ans de faire la princesse
blanche dans fort boyard
voilà vous m'avez donné ma chance dans
tpm puis depuis six ans si j'ai une
émission en région toutes les semaines
je sors une chronique je vais chez gens
partagent leur passion mais pour que
voulait tout faire de la télévision
après en fait pendant un an on est forcé
à faire date et les ruelles à des
interviews et tout ça alors qu'on n'a
pas forcément geek et à la célébrité
oui mais on on commence à aimer à
prendre du plaisir à savoir faire et
même si on voulait arrêter les gens
veulent quoi veulent nous voir à la
taylor avant de laisser la parole à vos
camarades qui sont vraiment de mauvaises
langues et y est une vie après les miss
france on va leur demander un petit qui
font un petit kif pour nous on a la
vidéo de votre victoire c'était en 2002
ont la balle passe à bavois la regarder
comme c'était beau à puce alain delon a
bah oui c'était alain delon sera pas
comment c'est fini la soirée
alors les amis y at il une vie après les
miss france guillaume louis va oui alors
oui mais bon ben moi j'adore les miss
france et j'avais demandé à sylvie
tellier à l'époque quand elle était miss
france je leur ai dit écoute je
m'occupais d'une petite chaîne de télé
en fait on vient les chercher pour miss
france parce que ces vagues depuis un
certain temps on est un mois j'étais je
suis incapable de vous dire le nom de la
miss france de cette année je ne sais
pas il y en a eu un peu beaucoup un
moment il ya eu la rupture avec sylvie
tellier et geneviève de fontenay
donc en fait on sait plus comment il
s'appelle ya une miss nationale masse
france miss prestige s'appelle cook
almaviva cook et du cou
en fait en les aidant elles soient elles
sont élues parce qu'elles sont jolies
mais elles n'ont pas vraiment de métier
donc après qu'elle veuille faire de la
télé c'est on vient les chercher parce
qu'elles sont miss france on sait pas
mettre un nom forcément sur leurs
visages et sous bar branché une question
mais en ce moment dans le sujet en mai
et risque ni thénard et donc c est la
star parce que l'on va partout la
télévision on la voit notamment dans des
dans des émissions n'est pas forcément
mises en avant pour des déçus
oui enfin pas forcément pour tous pour
des bonnes qualités est ce que c'est la
foire leur rend service
non mais ça nous fait le met déjà à la
télé on a envie de voir des belles
filles généralement effectivement ça
fait de l'audience et où il ya des
filles qui apprennent plus ou moins vite
donc qu'elle soit plus ou moins haut
avec ce fameux tremplin et puis ensuite
la les toutes nouvelles c'est normal que
vous les connaissez pas mais sonia
rolland ça fait je sais pas combien de
temps j'allais encore dix ans et iris
vous la verrez pas depuis 92 je pense et
linda hardy qui veulent faire la
télévision avec avec notre ami thierry
ardisson de 92 aujourd'hui j'en connais
pas une qui est fait derrière avocat me
posais une question exactement ça c'est
à chaque fois ils apparaissent à la télé
parce qu'elles sont jolies mais elle
transforme pas l'essai on n'a aucune
miss france à paris me tenir et métier
mais qui est également dans dans le
connecter miss france mais sinon quand
elles viennent à la télé fayçal à ce
qu'on a fait par exemple à nous qui
n'attendent ondaine que la beauté c'est
exactement ça on les engage uniquement
parce qu'elles sont belles heures oui
mais après je pars leur carrière après
les essais dans les émissions dites
normales on les engage uniquement pour
leur plastique on attend que ça devrait
être dévoilé aucune chance à aucune
chapelle 24 et les gens c'est idiot ça
tient au bout d'un moment on les oublie
on prend et on en fait alors ses murs
avec les miss mais bon oui j'ai très dur
avec emi ce qu'est ce que parce qu'elles
sont belles donc la régie c'est le
principe de l'élection de miss france
c'est la beauté quand même donc donc
nuit à paris salle et ça nous fait des
people nous en tant que presse people
pour l'année l'année cette année là où
l'année d'après oui il y en a certaines
qui restent mais voilà quoi toujours ce
magnifique à ses emails bala
kelly est très intéressant elle se voit
elle dit j'aime pas ces images pourquoi
pour moi c'est une espèce de bétaillère
qui rabaisse un peu la femme s'était mis
110 mm et france et on monte bien on
voit voilà on les monte bien de haut en
bas pour moi la question est beaucoup
plus violente c'est quand on est beau
est-ce qu'on vous faire une carrière
après d'ardian exemple mais voilà c'est
ça aussi la cesci difficile aujourd'hui
après le fait d'être miss france c'est
qu'elles deviennent de vrais
influenceurs parce que moi dans mon
agence qui gère des influences gêné d'or
me demande de grandes marques pour les
lourds trans qui veulent que des miss
parce qu'elle représente le chic la
beauté on comprend mieux classe c et
j'ai une vraie demande autour des miss
france possède aujourd'hui bien sûr non
ça on a une vraie demande sur les miss
france s'accordent très sens inverse
dont la conclusion est pour délit avant
d'oser été miss belle-fille
[Applaudissements]
il ya des gens qui rentrent à la télé
par l'humour d'autres entrent par la
beauté de notre ambitieuse bad buzz ou
ou voilà mais c'est vrai que les gens
très souvent veulent nous cantonner au
rôle de miss et tu vois moi j'ai été élu
il ya sept ans et on présente encore
comme ancienne miss alors oui ça doit me
faire plaisir mais je fais autre chose
aujourd'hui donc j'aime plus qu'on ne
parle forcément de sart c'est vrai mais
je donne comme la parole dans une
émission de télé vous parler de tout et
en plus très bien parce que vous avez
des avis tranchés sur les choses dont
vous n'êtes pas là que parce que vous
êtes belle rassurez vous